Ronaldo Beckham you've created this who
do you think should be on the right wing
Ronaldo he just doesn't like Ronaldo
wait stop stop stop stop st drop Ronaldo
won the bonor at Manchester United
before he was even the best version of
Ronaldo you know how insane that it
you're moving
M what's going on what's Happening good
on your goods let's go what's going on
right mate how you doing yeah good good
good don't mess this up you've got one
this is look this is really really we're
not going to agree we haven't started
yet and you arguing already this is
something you should enjoy we should
enjoy this you should you should well as
many United fans I don't know if there's
much to enjoy at the moment but don't
say that don't say that that's crazy I
mean we couldn't even do this for you
bro what we do we're sold 11 how much
sold that's all we do we come on listen
look this isn't about Brighton this is
about Manchester United all right
abolutely so look we have got kg and
flex joining us today and we're going to
be building the ultimate Manch United 11
if you can't agree between you I will
have final say that makes sense as a
neutral as a neutral okay so we're going
to be starting with goalkeepers today
all right so first kg do you want to
kick us off who you think should make it
oh that's not funny list I know you're
proud African he conf first African
goalie you know you're happy but yeah
maybe in another 15 years maybe but yeah
maybe all right go then seriously kick
us off you think we're going go
disrespect to Michaels immediately it
has to be I vanar I was thinking about
that heavy this morning vanar yeah it
makes sense again like he should be
there yeah but then P Michael is just
incredible even though he went to Man
City and I had to forgive him for that
pitch Michaels absolutely yeah the vasar
one's tight this is the one where I'm
always like cuz vanar won so much in a
short space of time at the back end of
his career as well if we would have had
a prime
and even when he was with man united it
was it was like a prime vanar but he was
like I said coming out for him he was he
was older but what he won in such a
condensed period the consistency he had
was ridiculous but the foundations the
original big man making himself big you
know
that you know the
original right strictly come
down that's what he did bro makes
himself big you know he was doing it
first first make big in terms of the
rest it would go schmeichel vesar de GE
I think it's fair to say we're going to
lock in yes absolutely who wants to do
the honors I'll do that there you go
lovely that's the theme of how to move
forward we just agree it's going to get
harder going get hard so you feel like
that was quite easy was quite easy
that's the easiest thing it was not the
easiest there's other easy ones in there
right the next one we've got is the
strikers and as I can see by both your
faces this is going to be a tough one oh
who wants to throw out a few names to
kick us off Andy call Wayne Rooney has
to go here wait it's going to bro I
promise you we're going to have some
issues rude
vanro way Rooney has to be right here
where's there's loads of Honor mentions
where's Van pery there's no what are you
talking about don't you dare put V pers
in the greatest the great you mention
just because you hate Arsenal so much
it's not about Arsenal it's van pery
coming and winning us the league it
doesn't matter single-handedly over like
can Rooney Ronaldo needs to be up here
as well by the way that's the last
league title we've ever won he is not
getting on this I'm just saying let's
respect him yeah you said it now we can
move on and Dwight yor there's a lot of
guys listen Andy Cole yeah yeah he's my
hero you leave him out absolutely I have
to have to should we put them out should
we put them out yeah let's put them out
let's put them out you know this is you
know can I just get rid of can I get rid
of certain yeah eliminate a few a
disrespect thing I have to do it I'm KN
going to do that
thank he was good but sorry bro Man City
move did that kill him yeah that killed
him shar's got a go listen one of the
most iconic goals in our history but it
we talking about the company you're in
here all right this is no we we are a
massive club and this is actually this
actually hurts when you look back and
look at the Quality that we've had then
we've had like martial injured all last
season didn't have a stri and this is
what we used to have no but this is what
it was what I'm saying this is what it
was yeah people like T Hughes and Sharon
are going n that's the levels van
Percy's got to go he can't just call him
just in the I want to keep him just over
there had a couple of good seasons one
of the league he's a cult hero he's not
a Manchester United great bro these are
Manchester United
greates yeah this is the elite company
he has to
play but there's but there's something
that there's another name that isn't on
here go on cuz for me I need Cristiano
Ronaldo as a striker you want him as a
striker because I've got other stuff
going on it you're not allowed to do it
I think I'm allowed to do that because
what Cristiano wait no no no no what
Cristiano R are you talking about then
whichever one you want when what one are
you talking about is the number nine for
Man United we're talking about the one
free Real Madrid this is Madrid this is
442 man we can allow to do it no but I
want to say you don't you can't play
yeah I understand Ronald Ronaldo it's
impossible it's not impossible it's
impossible that's ridiculous not that's
ridiculous Ronaldo won the balandor at
man united he helps us win two Champions
bro what do you think he's a better a
striker than he was a play him there
then you want to play be can't do that
play are you insane these are locked off
these These are noo areas let's change
the formation do you want to change
formation I don't think formation is
going to help we change the formation
you're the reason I support man you're
so you want to go 433 if you leave if
you leave him off the alltime list
you're taking it that's Drugs That's
Heavy I want to speak to someone that's
drugs you can't do it no but by doing by
by doing this by doing this yeah you
talk about drugs wait there from drugs
to counseling yeah because I'll tell you
what if you leave off who I think you're
going to leave off in any of these
positions you're not a man united fan no
but if I put Ronaldo there it's fine so
where's Beckham going to go I could
leave him out if you want to if you
there you go I could leave him out
you're not man un fan I am I am right
out we're going to have to push you boys
on a decision here I don't care I don't
care if Ronaldo doesn't get into this
team that's crazy but he's playing think
don't do the thing of why you don't like
Ronaldo anymore yeah cuz I know you
don't like Ronaldo anymore and he's the
reason I sport my United so what are you
doing he's playing it's because here we
got a big problem this is the whole we
do that later all right all right all
right all right yes yes yes yes yes
right let's lock those two names in
please there we go Rooney and can that
was hard man there was always going to
have to be a serious name who's going to
get left off with this I understand that
but I think you've gone the wrong way
let's go on to we're going to go on to
the right hand side now we've got three
names Ronaldo Beckham and Jon Park on
his right hand side park Gung no I'm not
I'm just saying park though respect he's
done he's a hero hero unbelievable free
lung park that's what call him free l
park l%
yeah but he's not going to be at the
table but Ronaldo Beckham you've created
this who do you think should be on the
right wing H come on you got to play
Ronaldo I had a Beckham on the right
hand side did he not win the Bal Andor
at man united well this is why he had to
be in my team well this is you want to
have this problem I because you've done
this I'm
not you know what's annoying you know
what's annoying do you know what's annoy
what you've done here is now I have to
stick with the two that I wanted to go
in this team because you've done this
now so Ronaldo Ronaldo has to be the
Casual playing yeah I know that's what
I'm saying that's what I'm saying so bad
why are you so angry no I love that
because of this yeah because of what's
about what's happening now you drop you
would drop Mr number seven yeah there's
no this is the seven first we're talking
about another seven right now we're
talking we're talking about Rockstar
foota we're talking we're talking about
like you said he went out of a spice
when we when we done the all time
England Grace this is we were talking
about this guy here you're just going to
just casually leave he had curtain and
it looked cool Gary had curtains and
looked dead Phil n had curtains and
looked
dead he had canro yeah he had all his
hairstyles he had a skin
head this is hairy 11 I know I
know no but I'm I'm starting with how
iconic he is best dead bull specialist
has ever been I play he's got a whole
he's got a whole movie name wait just to
be clear you Ronaldo he just doesn't
like Ronaldo wait stop stop st stop stop
him chistian don't let him do no no
basically because of the Pierce Morgan
thing the interview he's raised him he's
I raed
him so he would
happily so let me do the Ronaldo bit
because even though I think Ronaldo won
the batt Andor at Manchester United
before he was even the best version of
Ronaldo you know how insane that you're
moving mad do you know what do you know
if you get a corner David Beckham you
know Fergy time you know Fergy does that
one yeah yeah it's crazy it's a goal
yeah so what you're telling me you're
Ronaldo Cristiano Ronaldo doesn't make
it into your ultimate he does he made it
into mine but he's ruined it no I
haven't then put him in then drop
Beckham I know I I I spoke for this one
drop Beckham then go on I'm going to
give you the choice here you
go drop him I just want to remind you if
you can't make a decision let I will
have the final say don't cuz you're
going to do something no I W yeah I'm
going to go you know
what no
I need it to go to the
judge I do so wait who wait just to be
clear who are you voting for just to be
clear what's he done that for put your
put your player in there man okay hold
on who you going to vote for who who'
you vote for easily number seven bendy
Like Beckham is Beckham okay and you are
going to vote for Ronaldo to make it yes
you know Gary know had to learn how to
cross when he left Gary never one he
doesn't even do he's not even on the
right hand side he's a left it's not
it's left or up front for Ronaldo he's
not even out I don't mind if you put him
in I don't mind you could put him on the
left it's Beckham it's Beckham it's
Beckham for me I was going to have
Ronaldo up front and can and I was just
going to miss out that's what I was
going to do man united team but that
can't happen as all don't one big guy
has to miss out someone has to be the
Casual someone has be the Casual he can
be in Real Madrid all time 11 you know
what I'm going to keep him just in case
you want to discuss him for the left
hand side happy with that yeah cool
right next one this is going to be a mad
one got Center Midfield there a lot of
names you're saying easy it is easy easy
come on then four SCS and R king easy
that's it yeah this is probably the one
area of the pitch that is the easiest po
skulls who who we're going to straight
inant we can move in just in case just
in case Roy ke absolutely Roy Keane goes
in there oh now we' got Michael Carri
you mentioned him already special though
he is special he's special I'm going to
put him there just just just in case I
like that that's what I want really is
it that's how you want it I like that 12
players unfor all right so we locked in
skulls and Kean but just some out for us
why why those two these are probably one
of the reasons I support man united as
well is just everything that everything
you want the little the the Maestro the
magician like to play the way he did you
know they said when he even came they
say he's too small too short how's he
going to manage and this is like a
thinking man midfielder he like as soon
as you get to him the ball's gone you
know can p anywhere he's what they call
him satav what do you call it anywhere
like this guy is just he's Elite he's
great he could have played in any League
any country he's fantastic I feel like
SC always you know the you get the fake
quotes like zidan said this it's always
just make it up I've said P said loads
of things about SC I don't know let's
make up some
quotes zadan said that he wanted to be
Ginger and be last
go we we need have hair to do that to I
Roy Keane Roy Keane right was a
different type of player because you
look at skulls being Majestic Majestic
amazing on the ball Roy Keane had a
little bit of absolutely everything he
had Elite mentality he had that dog in
him yeah you look at the iconic clip of
you want to come pick on somebody come
pick on me yeah that was a awful
[Laughter]
Irish that's
fine got to be in game in game no it's G
right now it's in
game
do your job do your job do your job job
but R Keen yeah I'm talking about the
grit in terms of you you think about um
semi-final against Juventus right 99
sacrif Captain's performance goals do I
mean git in Midfield knew he was going
to miss the final made sure that man
united got to that final on my watch Rio
ferand even speaks about it like even
over the way he left the club R says
Rook was a guy you turned to when the
chips are down what we going to do Roy
where do we go from here you know
standards standards standards um and
could mix it with the very best and you
need for this team to win you need this
character in the team absolutely all
right let's lock those two in locked in
nice and easy locked in nice and easy
she taking shape now taking shape let's
go next up we've got the center ARs and
we're going to do them as a pair again
yeah yeah you look like you're ready to
go Yap Stam Yap Stam easy is that your
first one you think of yep them I know
why you're doing this cuz he y you can't
do it though Yap Stam you can't do it
who you think Yap Stam is fantastic and
I do want him in here but we have to go
off the best partnership that's ever
been at Man United and it's Rio and
viage it is but with
Rio that indiv individually individually
st's in there bro r no that would have
been amazing that really that's really
that's what it should have been why
can't we because the disrespect on
Village when that was the best
partnership and won the most in in that
time over a longevity period i Rio
wouldn't be the Rio like that so vid V
wouldn't have been the player of Rio wer
there but do you know what Rio would be
next to St next to Stam yeah I hear you
I hear you but Y St where does vid and
Rio
F hey you know our manager regrets
nothing he doesn't even regret let Roy
Keane leave in the way he did he still
talks about um yapan to this day
shouldn't let go of him he said bro he
there's a book that K bought out he said
he said he got it wrong got was the
biggest mistake of my life yeah yeah but
it happened it happened in the longevity
you make you want to a mistake don't do
it no it's not it's not a mistake look
what we run R VI that's our best ever s
about partnership I know what do you
mean no it's not regardless of them
being the best partnership he's still
going I can cuz Rio individually he's
better than vid show he so what we
talking about but he didn't do it long
enough bro because our manager ruined it
so you're going to where you going to
put your stand to the side like there a
nobody Fergy did come on and he it and
he regrets it I'm going to regret it too
but that's what it is oh the's got going
aside I can't believe I done that you
know I did this morning I woke up yeah
and I goes I'm putting Yap down in his
team I I this morning I said there's no
way he can tell me y not I actually did
the opposite I woke up and said Yan's
got to go in but vidit and ferand are
the best do hold okay let's bre this
down so R ferand you're both agreeing
absolutely okay but then on the other
side then Yap Stam and Man vid he's way
better than vid like for like player for
player who's the better one y it's Yap
Stam it is Yap Stam if you're going to
do if you're going to do it on it
depends whether you want it as a partner
ship of what they achieved or just the
individual players no cuz when if you're
11 I'm going to let you guys all right
Yap Stam Yap Stam yep St y y hon that
was that was my original thinking then I
went but our most our best duo there
been doesn't matter but if you would
have had Yap Stam for like seven eight
years next to Rio it would have been a a
stupid problem right let's lock it in
then you go give you f and I there you
go
we yeah it's proper that is solid I'll
give you that I'll give you that that's
this team is shaping up very nicely lie
can't lie next up we've got the left
hand side the left wing in particular
yes any names you want to throw out
there yeah you've got you've got the
obvious ones you got Ryan Giggs you got
Ronaldo as a candidate as well Ryan gigs
versus Arsenal are you doing actually
now to put Ronaldo in just because you
feel bad no essentially that's Ronaldo
for me was going to go left wing or up
front in the in my original team um but
with the way the team's gone and where
we're at currently the only space that
Ronaldo can get in now obviously is
potentially instead of Ryan gigs which
can't happen right we're going to have
to push you now so it's between Ronaldo
and Giggs it's Ryan Giggs Ryan Giggs 13
Premier League titles listen Ryan Ryan
gigs yeah the longevity of what he done
won everything there is to win in club
football the most appearances as well I
believe he is an incredible professional
from a young kid just whizzing through
Players I know the most famous thing was
the Arsenal situation but in terms of
the ball close to the feet like a George
bestes you know that dribbling taking on
players he was unbelievable he could he
could do everything I had the Ryan gigs
um VHS you know when is like soccer
skills with gigs and teach you like
inar still rubbish but um Lear thing you
learn the football wasn't for you that's
what you
learn that's what you learn that's why
he sitting there talking about yeah
exactly but he but he he was when you
talk about longevity though play into
into his like late 30s into 40s done
yoga done yoga look after himself and
was scor I think he scored in every
season played as well so it was Elite
mentality all right so just to be clear
just to put out there you're not you're
missing out Ronaldo this is your last
chance this is out of the team
Christiano Ronaldo does not make the
ultimate man united 11 it's a bad one
really it's all right you can make the
Real Madrid one it'll be fine you just
don't like him anymore no I like him I
like him but I'm just doing that that
look doesn't that look like amazing it's
amazing when you look at this United
United United yeah United does it remind
you the glory is this is Glory this is
it this is it this is it and this that's
how great he was because have if you
notice it's a throwback team apart from
and Ferdinand as well shows how good
they are shows how good they are to get
into that special team to get into a
'90s team where man united were the most
dominant force and Millennial team yeah
yeah Special popup right next up we got
right back now I'm going to be real with
you we struggled with this one I bet you
did yeah so there's there wasn't many
nam I can't even think of them I just
think of there's only one right back I
really could yeah but if he doing H
mentions what you're going to have
you're going to have brown john OA Valen
Valencia the
Silva um who else Ashley Young ra Rafael
told you told you told you but it's Gary
Neville Gary Neville Gary Neville talk
us through Gary Neville why was he so
good you know what I like the fact how
his game changed as well was a really
special thing about him when Beckham
left you know the the whole team really
struggled with it Gary Neville had to
like get to the by line whip the ball in
and then he was really showed that part
of his game and let's be honest seven
and eight you can never really pick a
timeing only when it was coming to
closer retirement is when he said ah
Gary nille couldn't do anymore but he
was missed the consistent you know and
that that's the his consistency and
always being there was brilliant I can't
even think of another right back because
of how consistent he was yeah it
everything kg said really I think Gary
Neville was quite modest about his own
career cuz he's a pundit now and there's
a lot of amazing players now sometimes
he mugs himself off a little bit says
I'd never be able to do that and but
let's not get it twisted before the Next
Generation came in Gary Neville was the
best fullback in the league yeah AB best
best right back in the league I know
it's Ashley Cole and stuff but I mean
like in his period of a of right back
there was none better than him in his
prime he was fantastic and him and
Beckham on that side he was brilliant on
the ball fantastic cross you know he was
good in a tackle and he understood the
game really Dependable he would say yeah
he didn't have the athleticism as the
kle Walkers or you know people like
Alonso Davis or you know Ashley Cole or
whatever he didn't have the athleticism
as people like that but his longevity
and his sort of ring leader leader as
well that's a real leader there as well
like you want you want a player like
that in your dressing room you you need
that right final one on the board we're
going for the left back spot mhm this
yeah there's one person that you
mentioned honorable mention in everra
but we know who we're getting with we're
talking about a Legend they're talking
about on the left hand side this guy
like and they people are forgetting how
good Dennis Dennis irn incredible you
talk about fake quotes yeah this is a
real quote F he said first name on the
team sheet easy first name on the team
Sheet both footed you know he's right
footed He could play left back he's to
take fre kicks he's to take the
penalties his understanding of the game
you talk about people who can actually
we we've done some stuff with Dennis and
actually I did ask him this about with
he was a fullback ahead of his time as
well he's unlike Gary Neville he could
have played in this era easily inverted
Dennis Owen are you insane oh my gosh
putting it on a six for players in that
and he said it he said he would have
loved to play in this era now he said it
himself um and he was a fantastic player
brilliant brilliant brilliant easily the
best left that we there you go this is
your Manchester United ultimate 11
chosen by KJ Flex y are you happy with
this I am the only the only un bit where
it was the Ronaldo situation for me and
you Lo in the comments get involved and
let us know I'm sure you will I'm really
happy about this team and this team goes
on to win major honors in the Premier
League right now as it on that how does
it get on in this era of football oh
wonder league wins the league absolutely
over the M current Man City side yeah
yeah the only the only problem sorry
Gary what might happen though because
it's a bit New Age though Gary might go
I'm in big big
trouble yeah no Gary's in trouble in the
new age I seem like this but this
schichel bro yeah it's insane o Ray Keen
skulls are you dumb finally we got to
pick a manager to go with this side who
are you guys going for
o
wheel it will be good to this
though but yeah fgy absolutely and uh
there you go that is your Manchester
United ultimate
[Music]
11 right the next one I know it's a bit
close to your heart obviously you're a
good power a certain person on that
board and he works for him now as well
delious you going to do to
your you lot shouldn't have done this
that's naughty you shouldn't have done
this random generator not random
generator random generator